English à la fac voici la question sur
laquelle planche en ce moment les
députés la ministre de l'Enseignement
supérieur a déposé un projet de loi et
un article fait débat proposer des cours
exclusivement en anglais ce n'est
pourtant pas nouveau dans ce laboratoire
de l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin spécialisé dans les
recherches articles où l'on accueille
des étudiants du monde entier les cours
sont déjà dans la langue de Shakespeare
je pense qu'il y a différentes publics
dans l'université de française auquel on
peut s'adresser et donc il n'est pas
inutile d'avoir des programmes qui sont
entièrement en anglais pour pouvoir
attirer un certain nombre de publics en
dehors des études de langues en revanche
en tant qu'Européen je tiens beaucoup à
la diversité des langues et donc il est
évident qu'il faut continuer à enseigner
aussi dans les langues nationales
ouvrir à l'onglet oui mais en préservant
la richesse du français Yann Bormes
d'origine allemande y est en tout cas
sensible les syndicats sont montés au
créneau plus largement contre l'ensemble
du projet de loi de la ministre
Geneviève cure à Sceaux mercredi ils
étaient 4000 à manifester à Paris donner
exceptionnellement à courant en anglais
oui monter des cursus en anglais pour
attirer des étudiants étrangers il me
semble que c'est assez illusoire déjà
parce que un étudiant qui veut étudier
en anglais il y aura plutôt dans un pays
anglophone que dans un pays francophone
le vrai problème de la loi c'est les la
privatisation de l'université donc c'est
ça qui est en cause ça dénatures la
fonction de l'université qui est de
permettre à tous les
étudiants quel que soit leur origine
sociale de
d'apprendre une discipline le projet de
loi pourrait être voté à l'Assemblée
nationale fin du mois les syndicats
annoncent d'autres mouvements